This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing.
这是一个I-Heart播客。保证是人类的声音。嘿，各位好吗？欢迎收听《艰难成长的教训》（Learn the Hardway），我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯（Kear Games）。这个空间探讨的是黑人男性的经历，进行在其他任何地方其实都不安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士交流。
How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%.
有多少男人穿着西装或铠甲。这向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须去使用它。请在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的平台上收听《艰难成长的教训》。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人所占的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。欢迎收听我的播客《2%》。
I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist,
我将在这个光怪陆离的现代世界中，剖析心理韧性、健身和培养抗挫力的科学。让自己经历一些磨难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《2%》。也就是“TWO%”。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约会过时，
they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On The Look Back at it podcast.
她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到他应得的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《女朋友们：相信我，宝贝》（The Girlfriends. Trust me, babe）。在《回看当年》（The Look Back at It）播客节目中。
From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year.
从1979年开始，对当时的我和我来说，那是一个重大的时刻。84年对我也很重要。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。和我们的朋友、同行喜剧演员以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）聊80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。
It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to another episode. New listeners, all listeners, wherever you're. are in the world. I am so glad that you have joined us for an episode that I am so very excited about.
那是一个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。请在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《回看当年》（Look Back at It）。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》（The Psychology of Your 20s），在这个播客里，我们探讨二十岁时面临的一些重大生活改变和转折，以及它们对我们心理的意义。大家好。欢迎回到本节目。欢迎收听另一期节目。新听友、老听友，无论你们身在世界的哪个角落。我非常高兴你们能来收听这一期我感到无比兴奋的节目。
It's been a long time coming. It's been in the works for a while. I'm bringing on a beautiful guest, a beautiful friend to talk about things like identity, rituals, creative, inspiration, everything and anything in between. Without further ado, I'd love for you to introduce yourself. Hello. Hello. Hi. Hi. Um, nice. to meet you all. Yeah. Big fan. Oh, you're a big fan. Big fan. Big fan of the audience. Big, big, big fan. So who are you? That's a good question. Yeah. Who am I? No, my name is Claude Bailey. My pronouns are they, them, they and them. I'm a filmmaker and more recently have started doing a lot of work in queer youth, queer youth art projects, workshops,
这一天我们等了很久。这个企划筹备了一段时间。我请来了一位美丽的嘉宾，一位美丽的朋友，来谈论身份认同、仪式感、创作灵感，以及介于两者之间的万事万物。废话不多说，我想请你做个自我介绍。你好。你好。嗨。嗨。嗯，很高兴认识大家。是的。超级粉丝。哦，你是超级粉丝。超级粉丝。观众的超级粉丝。超级、超级、超级粉丝。那么你是谁？这是一个好问题。对。我是谁？不，我叫克劳德·贝利（Claude Bailey）。我的代词是they、them、they和them。我是一名电影制作人，最近开始涉足很多酷儿青年、酷儿青年艺术项目、工作坊、
development programs. I don't really know how to sum it up, but I am a big advocate for giving queer youth opportunities to express themselves. And a lot of my filmmaking work, because I write, direct and produce is, you know, centering queer youth as well. I just, I love them. They're the future. They are. They are the future. You did an amazing film recently, didn't you? I did. Can you talk about it a little bit? I feel like people would love to hear about it. Yeah, I made a film called Right Here. It premiered at Sydney Film Festival, which was... Yeha! Oh, yeah! Oh, yeah! Well, Sydney Film Festival!
发展项目等相关工作。我其实不知道该怎么总结，但我坚决主张给酷儿青年提供表达自我的机会。而且我的很多电影工作，因为我集编剧、导演和制片于一身，你知道，也是以酷儿青年为核心的。我就是，我爱他们。他们是未来。他们是的。他们就是未来。你最近拍了一部很棒的电影，对吧？是的。能稍微谈谈吗？我觉得大家会很想听听。对，我拍了一部名为《就在这里》（Right Here）的电影。它在悉尼电影节上首映，那真的是……耶！哦，耶！哦，耶！哇，悉尼电影节！
No, when I got the email, I screamed in the street. It was a really gorgeous moment, and I called my best friend and I was like, it happened, it happened. Were you crying? I did cry. I would be crying. Yeah, it was, I always went to that festival when I was much younger and wanted to be a filmmaker, so then getting to have my film there was a really big moment. But that film was my fifth short film and my last. I think. Really?
不，当我收到邮件时，我在街上尖叫了。那是一个非常美妙的时刻，我给我的最好朋友打电话说，成了，成了。你哭了吗？我哭了。我会哭的。是的，那真是，我年轻得多的时候总是去那个电影节，梦想成为一名电影制作人，所以后来能在那里展映我的电影，真的是一个非常重大的时刻。但那部电影是我的第五部短片，也是最后一部。我想是的。真的吗？
Yeah, I'm done with short films. Anyway, but it was about a young non-binary person. They came out to their parents and their birthday. It didn't go very well. You don't really see that. And then they materialize at their future self's birthday party and they see the life they're going to have and the community they're going to have
对，我不再拍短片了。不管怎样，它是关于一个年轻的非二元性别者的。他们在生日那天向父母出柜。结果不是很顺利。你其实很少在荧幕上看到这种情节。然后，他们在自己未来自己的生日派对上具象化地出现，看到了他们将要拥有的生活和将要拥有的社群，
because I think a really big thing is that when you're a teenager or a kid, queer youth generally, you don't have any control over your environment. You don't have any control over your school, over your family. And so I wanted to give young people some tangible hope that's like, if right now your environment is not it, it's coming. I promise you, because it happened for me, and it happened for so many queer folk around me,
因为我认为一个非常重要的事情是，当你还是一个青少年或孩子，也就是酷儿青年时，你对自己的环境没有任何控制权。你对自己的学校、家庭没有任何控制权。所以我想给年轻人一些切实可见的希望，那就是：如果眼下的环境并非你所愿，它终究会改变，我向你保证，因为这发生在我身上，也发生在我身边的许多酷儿朋友身上，
so it's coming. You just got to, like, unfortunately, hold tight because it's all yours. And that's what the film's about. Oh my God, that's an amazing message. Yeah. That is beautiful. And we're going to bring it to schools all around Australia this year. I'm working with Wear It Purple, which is a non-for-profit queer youth organization,
所以它就要来了。你只需要，嗯，不幸的是，咬紧牙关坚持住，因为这一切都属于你。这就是这部电影的主题。天哪，这是一个了不起的信息。是的。太美妙了。今年我们将把它带到全澳大利亚的学校。我正在与“穿出紫色”（Wear It Purple）合作，这是一个非营利性的酷儿青年组织，
and we're going to try and get it to young people all around to be like, here, have this little nugget of joy. Yeah. As someone who, like, obviously we both grew up in Australia, I don't think there was any queer representation in any of my curriculum growing up. None at all. Oh, not in curriculum. No way. In any facet, like, you know, and I went to a pretty progressive school, and even within that environment, it was like, this isn't really spoken about.
我们打算把它带给各地的年轻人，让他们觉得：给你，带上这点小小的快乐。是的。作为一个，当然我们俩都是在澳大利亚长大的，在我成长过程中，我的任何课程里都没有任何酷儿代表性。完全没有。哦，课程里绝对没有。绝不可能。在任何方面都没有，你知道的，而且我上的是一所相当进步的学校，即便在那种环境下，也是觉得：这其实是不被公开谈论的。
And it's not something that was like, I think people had access to or were able to be educated on, which is so bizarre to me because I'm like it does make up such an amazing vibrant part of our society. It's just part of everyday life for so many people, even people who aren't queer. So I'm really excited that you're able to do that. Well, that's what's very interesting is that I'm working with a lot of queer youth right now, and they have a lot more access to online spaces and representation, but what I'm finding is that even though they have all this access, they have the terminology, they have the language, they know it's out there,
而且这也不是人们能够接触到或能够接受教育的事情，这对我来说太离奇了，因为我觉得它构成了我们社会中如此美妙、充满活力的一部分。对许多人来说，这只是日常生活的一部分，甚至对那些并非酷儿的人也是如此。所以我很高兴你能做这件事。嗯，非常有趣的一点是，我目前正在和很多酷儿青年合作，他们有更多的渠道接触到网络空间和代表性，但我发现，尽管他们拥有所有这些渠道，他们有专业术语，有语言来表达，他们知道这些是存在的，
they still, though, cannot touch it. It's beyond their grasps. And at a lot of schools, there's the QSA, the Queer Straight Alliance, and different pride groups, and there's those spaces, but it's still out of grasp, it's still not in reach. And so I think it's still extremely important. Yeah. That's actually a really good point because I do feel like with the rise of social media and things like that,
但他们仍然无法触及它。它超出了他们的触及范围。在很多学校里，有QSA（酷儿异性恋联盟）和不同的骄傲组织，也有这些空间，但它仍然是遥不可及的，依然无法企及。所以我认为这仍然极其重要。是的。这确实是一个很好的观点，因为我确实觉得随着社交媒体的崛起以及诸如此类的事情——
which we talk about quite a bit on the podcast and how it's changed our dynamics with other people and our relationships to ourselves. The fact that you're like, that still isn't something that's like tangible for them. But I want to talk about this a little bit more like how you talked about how your film the concept of your film was giving that hope to queer youth. Was that something that you drew a lot from your personal experience? How much of that was really like thinking about your past and thinking about how you came to really like embrace and show people your identity?
我们在播客中经常讨论这一点，以及它如何改变了我们与他人的动态关系以及我们与自我的关系——你提到这仍然不是对他们而言触手可及的东西。但我还想多聊聊这个，比如你谈到你的电影，你电影的概念是给酷儿青年带来那种希望。这在很大程度上汲取了你的个人经历吗？其中有多少成分真的是在回想你的过去，回想你是如何真正开始接受并向人们展示你的身份的？
Yeah, well, I went to a Catholic or girls school. Oh, wow. Yeah. Positive. Yeah. And I was in the closet, but I didn't even know I was in the closet. Like I was in Narnia and I was living there. And, like, I was in love with my best friend in high school, but I didn't, that didn't equate to me being queer.
是的，嗯，我上的是一所天主教女子学校。哦，哇。是的。肯定。是的。而且我当时在衣橱里，但我甚至不知道自己躲在衣橱里。就像我身处纳尼亚王国还在里面安家了。而且，就像我在高中时暗恋我最好的朋友，但我并没有，这并不等同于我是个酷儿。
I was just like, oh. I love her. I love her, but I'm not a lesbian. Yeah. And I don't identify as a lesbian now. Anyway. Interesting. But I think that I didn't even have any of the tools to start to understand who I was or how I identified.
我当时只是想，哦。我爱她。我爱她，但我不是女同性恋。是的。而且我现在也不觉得自己是女同性恋。不管怎样。有趣。但我觉得我当时甚至没有任何工具来开始了解我是谁，或者我是如何认同自己的。
That wasn't, that wasn't around me whatsoever. we were all boy crazy and yeah it just that again that's what's so interesting about young people now is that they do have the access to understand what the queer world is like and what is out there but they don't they can't grasp but i didn't even know i had no idea so i think back to my younger self and i have so much love for them i've so much love because not that i had a really great upbringing and I had a really gorgeous time in high school but I just never really felt like myself. I never felt comfortable in my skin. I never really like I never had any high school boyfriends and everyone did and I just thought that I was broken and all the sexual experiences
那根本不是，我周围完全没有这些。我们都对男孩疯狂，对，这再次说明了现在年轻人有趣的地方在于，他们有途径去了解酷儿世界是什么样的，外面有什么，但他们做不到，他们无法掌握，而我当时甚至都不知道，我毫无概念。所以我回想年轻时的自己，我对那个时期的自己充满了爱，充满了爱——倒不是说我的成长经历有多棒，我在高中的时光也无比美妙，但我只是从来没有真正做过自己。我在自己的皮肤里从未感到自在。我从来没有，就像我从来没有过高中男友，而所有人都有，我当时就觉得自己坏掉了，所有的性经历——
that I had were never fulfilling. Yeah. So I always just thought oh something's wrong with me and so one thing, like I always say that queerness is the most beautiful thing about my life. It really is. In every facet, like, we'll probably go into it. But I just, I didn't even know. And so when I started, when I did come out and then started to enter community, I was like, whoa. I just, I was blind. Now I can see. Like, it's, it's, it was life changing. That sounds like a genuinely, incredibly inlining experience. And one that I think that a lot of us don't really get, right, like coming to terms with some part of our identity that has been concealed for some time, even people who are listening to this who may not identify as queer, that's not something that happens all of the time.
我都从未感到满足。是的。所以我总是以为，哦，我身上出了问题。所以有一件事，我总是说，酷儿身份是我生命中最美好的事物。真的是这样。在方方面面，我们稍后可能会深入探讨。但我当时甚至根本不知道。所以当我开始，当我真正出柜并开始融入社群时，我心想：哇。我只是，我以前是个瞎子。现在我看得见了。这简直是，这是改变人生的一听。听起来这确实是一次令人难以置信的、启迪心灵的经历。而且我想，我们很多人其实并没有真正经历过这种体验，对吧？比如坦然接受我们身份中被隐藏了很长一段时间的某一部分，甚至对于那些收听节目的、可能并不自认为是酷儿的人来说，这也是不常发生的事情。
But I do just want to, like, take a step back here and, you know, you talked about how your identity has kind of shifted from your adolescence, even your childhood maybe, to, like, your adulthood. But, like, how would you define it now? Or how would you define it now? How would you define it? find your queer identity or the broader queer identity in general? Big question. We can, we can, we can, we can, we can, take it in bite-sized chunks. I just kind of want to know like that, you know, like how you said you were in the closet and you didn't even know it.
但我只是想在这里退后一步，你知道，你谈到了你的身份如何从青春期、甚至可能是童年时期，转变到了成年时期。但是，你会如何定义它呢？或者你现在会如何定义它？你将如何定义，你如何定义你的酷儿身份或更广泛的酷儿身份？好大的问题。我们可以，我们可以，我们可以，把它拆成小块来回答。我只是想知道，你知道的，就像你说的，你以前躲在衣橱里，甚至自己都不知道。
Yeah. And now you're this amazing individual who is able to impact young people's lives with your message, with your stories. Like, what was the kind of journey from that place when you're in high school to the place you are now? I think the biggest part of it was visibility. I only really understood these things within me when I saw it in others. That was, and also experience.
是的。而现在你成了一个了不起的人，能够用你的信息、你的故事去影响年轻人的生活。从高中时的那个状态到现在的状态，这一路的心路历程是怎样的？我认为其中最大的一部分是可见性。我只有在别人身上看到这些时，才真正理解了自己内心的这些东西。那是，还有经验。
Like, I don't know, I kind of branched into two sections, like sexuality and gender, because they are completely different. And I think a lot of people bunch gender and sexuality together because it's under the LGBTQIA plus, you know, header. Yeah. But they're such different, and also they intercross a lot as well. But for me, it was very separate. I realized I was gay or queer first, and that was this slow experience through relationships
就像，我不知道，我基本上分成了两部分，性倾向和性别，因为它们完全是两码事。而且我认为很多人把性别和性倾向混为一谈，因为它们都被归在LGBTQIA+这个标签下面，你知道的。是的。但它们是如此不同，同时它们又有很多交织。但对我来说，这是非常分开的。我先是意识到自己是同性恋或酷儿，这是一个缓慢的过程，通过恋爱关系，
and through having, like, I remember when I had my first crush outside of the person I loved in high school, it was very beautiful because I was like, oh, this wasn't just a one-time thing. This is actually something inside of me, and it took a while to, walk that path because I had never done it before. I didn't know anyone. I felt like that one I did kind of alone and it was very slow and it also took a lot of me breaking down so many barriers that I had about me being broken. Yeah. That came from... Which is such a hard experience to think if you're like it kind of hurts me to think that you ever thought of yourself that way. I thought of myself that way for such a long time on the other side of that was the most liberating and healing thing.
以及通过拥有——我记得当我在高中喜欢的那个人之外有了第一个暗恋对象时，那是极其美妙的，因为我想，哦，这不仅仅是一次性的。这其实是我内心深处的东西，而且走过这条路花了一段时间，因为我以前从未这样做过。我不认识任何人。我觉得那次我是独自一人走过来的，过程非常缓慢，而且这也需要我打破很多关于“我坏掉了”的枷锁。是的。这些枷锁来自于……这真是一段艰难的经历，一想到你曾那样看待自己，我就觉得有点心疼。我曾很长一段时间都那样看待自己，而在那对立面的，是最具解放性和疗愈意义的事情。
And that's why I say queerness is one of the most gorgeous things about my life because it was like, oh, these things, yeah, yeah, they were not working for you for many different reasons. Let's give you another avenue to explore yourself. And through that, I was able to feel lovable. And it was very relationship-based. But gender has been the most personal thing to me. And it was through, I guess, another relationship. I met someone who became one of my best friends who was trans, is trans,
这就是为什么我说酷儿身份是我生命中最美妙的事情之一，因为它让我觉得：哦，这些东西，对，对，它们在很多方面对你不管用。让我们给你另一条途径去探索自我。通过那条途径，我得以感受到自己是值得被爱的。这在很大程度上是基于关系的。但性别对我的意义则是最私人的。它是通过，我想是另一段关系。我遇到了一个人，他成了我最好的朋友之一，是个跨性别者——是跨性别者，
and I saw in them or him what I always felt inside of me. And that's why I say visibility. I saw it and I went, hey, I really feel this thing. And I can't really describe it, but I just feel it. And then I started asking friends to use they, them again, because I had met other non-binary people and it just felt. right. It didn't really make sense. I didn't understand it, but it just felt right. And then people started using they, them. And it's not even about the words, to be honest.
我在他身上看到了我一直在自己内心深处感受到的东西。这就是为什么我说可见性。我看到了，然后我说：嘿，我真的有这种感觉。我其实无法描述它，但我就是能感觉到。然后我开始请朋友们再次用 they/them 来称呼我，因为我遇到过其他非二元性别者，那种感觉对了。这其实说不通。我并不理解它，但感觉就是对的。然后大家就开始用 they/them 来称呼我。老实说，这甚至与词汇无关。
It's just about a feeling. What do you mean? It's not about the words, because I feel like, and I just feel like this is such an interesting thing, because I think when we think about the political space and whatever and how politics and personal opinion and public opinion interacts with our lives, like a big discussion is around like the use of pronouns. That's like the most exhausting part of all of it is. that our identity as queer or trans people is political now and it's fucked. Am I allowed to swear? Yeah, it is fucked because you know what?
这完全只是一种感觉。这话怎么说？这与词汇无关，因为我觉得，而且我觉得这是一个非常有趣的事情，当我们思考政治空间、无论政治、个人观点和公众舆论如何与我们的生活互动时，一个很大的讨论就是围绕代词的使用。所有这一切中最让人精疲力竭的部分是，
I feel like only like the people who are oppressed, their lives become political. It's true. It sucks. Men's lives are not political as much as like, you know, a heterosis man might want to say that like, oh, my life is political because I could be cancelled. That's not a political thing the same way that like abortion is a political. thing or like, you know, access to curriculum or schools if you're someone who is transgender or non-binary is a fucking political thing these days. That's why I say that if I had it my way, I would not talk about my gender experience with anyone because I don't have words for it still.
我们的身份作为酷儿或跨性别者现在变成了一个政治议题，这太他妈糟糕了。我可以骂脏话吗？是的，这太糟糕了，因为你知道吗？我觉得只有那些遭受压迫的人，他们的生活才会变成政治议题。确实如此。太糟糕了。男人的生活并不是那么政治化，尽管一个顺性别异性恋男人可能会想说：哦，我的生活是政治化的，因为我可能会被取消资格。那可不是什么政治议题，就像堕落（注：原文如此，指堕胎）是一个政治议题，或者如果你是一个跨性别者或非二元性别者，对课程或学校的准入现在是一个他妈的政治议题一样。这就是为什么我说，如果由我做主，我绝不会跟任何人谈论我的性别体验，因为我至今仍无法用言语来形容它。
It is always been based in feeling and I can't really summarize it. And what sucks is that pronouns are such an external thing. People can misgender you every single day. People say you're coming out every single day. And that is exhausting. And I wish I could, I just always define my gender as like a floating bob in the ether, which makes cis people go, what the fuck I'm not about? But it's kind of a beautiful metaphor. I just, I don't feel like man, I don't feel like women, I just want to exist and not be
它一直都根植于感觉，我也无法真正总结它。糟糕的是，代词是如此外在的东西。人们每天都可能对你使用错误的性别代词。人们说你每天都在出柜。这让人精疲力竭。我希望我能，我总是把我的性别定义为太空中的一个漂浮气泡，这会让顺性别者觉得：这他妈到底是什么鬼？但这其实是一个美丽的隐喻。我只是，我不觉得自己是个男人，我不觉得自己是个女人，我只想存在着，不被视为其中任何一种，巴拉巴拉。但我还是会谈论它，因为正是可见性让我获得了做自己的权利。所以我必须这么做。
seen as either, blah, blah, blah. But I will talk about it because visibility is what granted me to feel like myself. So I will do this. So hopefully someone can. listen and go, oh, I feel that within me as well, because that is the most beautiful gift we can give each other, is that feeling of coming home to yourself. So I will do it because I want others to feel this way, but it's exhausting. It's the most personal thing. Like, just imagine any part of your identity that is like inside of you that you don't have words for it. It's like a little locked
这样希望有人能听了之后会说：哦，我在自己内心深处也有这种感觉，因为我们能给彼此最美妙的礼物，就是那种回到自己内心的感觉。所以我愿意这样做，因为我希望其他人也能有这种感受，但这确实太累人了。这是最私密的事情。试想一下，你身份中任何深藏在你内心、你无法用言语表达的部分。它就像一个小小的带锁盒子。
box. Having to find words for it and be able to, you know, talk about it on panels and make work about it, it's a lot. And I don't, I don't hate it. I have found a way to love it because now I am finding ways to give other young people the opportunity to make work about it and, and create, have expression with it all. But it's a really confusing thing. Yeah. Oh my gosh, I can only imagine. And it's actually really interesting for me to hear and be like, I'm asking you these questions right now and the fact that you've like learned to love this thing. But then I think about my own experience, like no one's ever questioned my identity that way.
必须为它找到言语，并能够在小组讨论中谈论它，围绕它进行创作，这真的压力很大。我并不，并不讨厌它。我已经找到了去爱它的方式，因为现在我正在寻找方法，给其他年轻人创造机会，让他们围绕它进行创作，并进行表达。但这确实是一件非常让人困惑的事情。天哪，我完全可以想象。而且听到这些对我来说真的很有趣，心想：我此刻在问你这些问题，而你已经学会了去爱这个东西。但随后我想到了我自己的经历，从来没有人那样质疑过我的身份——
We kind of have it easy. Like I never have to explain that because it falls into a very like easy box for people to understand. And I really do respect what you're saying about how it's like it comes with a lot of almost emotional burden. Would you say that's the right word for it? Emotional labor. Emotional labor. Yeah. but yet you still feel this duty to do it.
我们某种程度上过得很轻松。因为我永远不需要解释那些，因为它很容易就被归入一个让人们易于理解的范畴。我真的很尊重你所说的，这伴随着几乎是某种情感上的负担。你会说这是最合适的词吗？情感劳动。情感劳动。是的。但你仍然觉得有责任去做这件事。
I think what's really difficult is that I people, so for example, someone on the street, your family member, anyone asks you these questions about your transness, your queerness. And for them, it's just another chat, another discussion, another thing they're curious about. It's a dinner table conversation. For you, it is the most personal and sacred part. And these conversations, some, are really beautiful and healing and gorgeous and I don't think they shouldn't happen. That's how we bridge understanding. But there is a lot of times that there is no acknowledgement of how much
我认为非常困难的是，人们——比如，街上的某个人、你的家庭成员、任何人——会问你关于你的跨性别身份、你的酷儿身份的这些问题。对他们来说，这只是又一次闲聊、又一次讨论、又是一个他们好奇的问题。这是一场餐桌上的谈话。而对你来说，这是最私密、最神圣的部分。这些对话中，有些非常美妙、具有疗愈作用、十分精彩，我不认为它们不该发生。这就是我们弥合理解的方式。但很多时候，人们并没有意识到，来自边缘化群体的这个人，必须付出多少情感劳动，因为他们一直在经历如此之多的事情。他们经历着人们在Instagram上说难听的话，或者在街上指指点点，这不仅仅是又一次的餐桌谈话，而是意味着他们不得不拉开那个抽屉，掏出他们不得不绞尽脑汁去思考如何谈论这些事情的备忘卡。这太，而且太私人了。我觉得，这是我总是想对你说的，这对你来说是餐桌谈话。对我来说，这是我的心。是的。我想这与我们之前谈论的话题不谋而合，即它如何被政治化了，而我们身份的其他元素——除了可能宗教之外——很少有被政治化的，即便如此，我认为情况也完全不同。你知道现在总能听到那种少数群体奥运会的说法，我们身份的如此多的部分现在都被政治化了。是的，这让人困惑，你知道，如果你说——老实说，自从以非二元性别出柜以来，我在工作上得到了更多更多的机会，这很有趣。我心想：哦，好吧，酷，我所有的情感劳动，我想它正以这种奇怪、陌生的方式得到回报，但世事无所谓好坏。它就是这样，它就是它本身。是的，这真是一个很好的心态。你真是个斯多葛派。我总是说，克劳德是个斯多葛派享乐主义者。你热爱生活所包含的一切，但你很清楚它是有限的。
emotional labour the person from the marginalised group has to do because they're experiencing so much all the time. They're experiencing people saying horrible things on Instagram or saying things on the street that this isn't just another dinner table conversations, is them having to like, you know, pull out that drawer and bring out their palm cards that they've had to work at how to talk about these things. It's, and it's just, it is so personal. And I think it's, it's something that I always like to say to you, it's a dinner table conversation. To me, it's my heart. Yeah. And I guess that kind of links back with what we were talking about how it's become quite politicized in a way that very few other elements of our identity, other than like probably
处于边缘化群体的个人必须付出情感劳动，因为他们时时刻刻都在经历着这一切。他们经历着人们在Instagram上说出可怕的话，或者在街上说三道四，这不仅仅是又一次的餐桌闲聊，而是他们不得不像，你知道的，拉开抽屉，拿出他们精心准备好如何谈论这些事情的提示卡。这是，而且它太私人了。我想这正是，我总是想对你说的，这是一个餐桌上的话题。对我和我的内心而言，是的。我想这与我们刚才讨论的内容联系在了一起，它如何以一种极少其他身份特征会出现的方式变得极具政治色彩，除了可能
religion have become politicized and even then it's very different I think like it's like the minority yeah Olympics you hear about these days that like every so many parts of our identity are politicized now yeah it's confusing that you know if you say and honestly since coming out as non-binary I have risk gotten so many more opportunities work-wise and it's interesting I I go, oh, okay, cool, all my emotional labor, I guess it's coming through this way in a weird, strange way, but nothing's good or bad. It's just, it's just what it is. Yeah, which is a great way. You're such a stoic. I always say, Claude, is a stoic hedonist. You love life for what it contains, but you're very much like it's finite, I guess.
生命是脆弱的，所以你最好尽情享受。是的，哦，当然。考虑到这一点，我觉得你一直在谈论这种情感劳动，我认为像我这样的人是无法理解的，对吧？我永远无法以你在你这个年纪已经理解的方式去理解它。有没有什么事是你觉得：好吧，我希望人们能理解我这一点，或者理解像我这样的人，或者理解和我建立社群的这些人，而这些是平时不怎么被谈论的？你会说，有什么是你如果有机会想要纠正的巨大误解，或者你想说：好吧，你知道，你在和家人进行餐桌谈话。你希望从来没有人问过什么问题，是你现在就可以纠正的？我觉得我最主要的一点是告诉他们：你不需要理解它，但要尊重它。我很乐意看到你试着去理解它，并带着同理心、开放的心态以及倾听的意愿来交流，但你不需要去理解成为一个非二元性别者意味着什么，或者成为一个跨性别者意味着什么，或者这一切的逻辑是什么。这其实不管你的事。
Yeah, the fragility of life, so you might as well enjoy it. Yeah. Oh, yeah, absolutely. Well, with that in mind, I feel like you're talking a lot about this emotional labour, which I think that someone like me can't understand, right? Like, I'm never going to understand it the way that you've already understood it at your age. Is there anything that you're like, okay, I wish people would just understand this about me or about the people that are like me or about the people that I have community with that isn't talked about much? Like, what would you say is a big misunderstanding that if you had the opportunity you
是的，生命的脆弱性，所以你最好尽情享受。哦，是的，绝对是。带着这种想法，我觉得你谈了很多关于这种情感劳动的内容，我认为像我这样的人是无法理解的，对吧？就像，我永远无法以你在这个年纪已经理解的那种方式去理解它。有没有什么事让你觉得，好吧，我希望人们能理解我这一点，或者理解像我这样的人，或者理解与我志同道合的社群中那些不太被人谈论的事情？你会说，如果给你机会，最大的误解是什么？
could correct or something that you would love to be like, okay, you know, you're at a dinner table conversation with your family. What's a question you wish wasn't asked that you could correct right now? I think my main thing is to tell them you don't have to understand it to respect it. I love if you are trying to understand it and come from a place of empathy and openness and that you want to listen, but you don't have to understand what it means to be
你也许可以根据你们的关系和对方的情况来问，但你不需要为了尊重它而去理解它。是的。这是最主要的一点，因为
non-binary or what it means to be trans or like the logistics of it all. That's not really your business. And you maybe can ask depending on the relationship and the person, but you don't have to understand to just respect it. Yeah. That's the main thing because
这是——我总是说，如果有人将他们的脆弱和对这一切的见解交给你，那是一种礼物，因为他们每天都在经历这些，他们一直在和他们的所有朋友以及生活中的人谈论这些。所以如果他们想把这些分享给你，那真的很美妙。但这应该，就像，你应该把它当成一份礼物来对待，而不是仅仅当作你随手拿走的东西。
it is, I always say it is a gift if someone gives you their vulnerability and their insights in all of this, because they're living in every day and they're talking about it to all of their friends and people in their life all the time. So if they want to give that to you, that's really gorgeous. But it should be, like, you should handle it as a gift, not as just something that you take.
是的，我认为这是一种对待许多事情的极佳态度。就像有人在给你他们的时间和精力，以及他们精挑细选的话语，正如你所说，那些几乎是信息和需要计划说出口的事情的“闪卡”。你有没有发现在与家人的对话中，有些人根本不想去理解，或者根本不想去尊重？是的，一直都有。随时都在发生。当一个人只是出于好奇、想要了解时，你一瞬间就能闻出来；而当一个人根本不在乎时，那是完全不同的。
Yeah, which I think is like a great attitude with many things. Like someone's giving you their time and their energy and they're very careful. thought out words like you said you know those um flashcards almost of information and things that they need to plan to say have you have you found that like in the conversations you've had with family that there's people who haven't wanted to understand or haven't wanted to respect yeah all the time happens all the time you can sniff it instantly when someone is inquisitive and curious and wants to know and it's very different when someone doesn't give a fuck.
你是怎么看出区别的？因为我觉得最初的提问方式可能很相似。你就是能看出来，很多时候区别在于语气的某种争论意味。这真的很难，因为他们在争论你的身份。是的。而且我想这也完全不管他们的事，这其实很奇怪。
Yeah. How can you tell the difference? Because I feel like the line of questioning to begin with might be quite similar. You can just, a lot of it is in the tone if someone feels like they're arguing with you to some extent. And that's really hard because they're arguing about your identity. Yeah. It's not, no of their business, I guess, as well, which is the strange thing.
还有，他们是真心想去理解，还是——我不知道是“还是”什么，但如果他们……或者说评判或争论，我想。但他们来这里是为了说：嘿，我其实不太明白……就像我生活中那些并非酷儿的人，他们会坐下来对我说：嘿，我太爱你了，我真的很想更多地理解你身上这部分。你能多跟我讲讲吗？那真的很美妙。
And also if they want to actually understand. versus, I don't know what versus, but if they... Or judge or argue, I guess. But they're here to be like, hey, I don't really get... Like, I love when people in my life who, you know, aren't queer, sit me down and be like, hey, I love you so much and I really want to get, like, understand this part of you more. Can you tell me about it more? And it's something that was really beautiful.
我拍的那部电影，里面的男主角，是一个惊艳的、非常惊艳的非二元性别者，我非常崇拜他们，他们给我讲了一个非常美妙的故事，我觉得他们不会介意我分享出来。他们的妈妈也是一位非常优秀的电影制作人，我是她的超级粉丝。她曾对她说：“我爱你的酷儿身份，我想更多地了解它，这是我最喜欢你的一点。”我当时听了都哭了，因为我想：天哪，这太震撼了。我听够了“尽管如此我还是爱你”或者“不管怎样我都爱你”，我甚至希望你“因为这个而爱我”，因为这是我最喜欢我自己的地方之一。是的，我这么说不是针对家庭，我只是泛指，这真的是一个人身上非常美妙的特质。是的，我希望每个人都能成为酷儿，这是活在这个世上最棒的事情，真的是这样。为什么这么说？当你在谈论——嗯，我想这就是我们谈论的可见性、社群，还有社群本身。这甚至超越了人际关系和酷儿亲密关系，那也同样惊艳。
The film I made, the actor in it, the lead, is this amazing, um, is this amazing, uh, non-binary person who I adore and they told me this really beautiful story that I feel like they won't mind me sharing um the their mom who's also this amazing filmmaker who I'm a big fan of um she was like I love your queerness I want to understand it more it's one of my favorite things about you I cried because I was like oh my gosh that's stunning I've heard enough of oh I'll love you despite this or I love you no matter what even like I want you to love me because of this because it's one of my favorite things about me yeah and I don't mean this with like family I just mean this generally it's like a gorgeous thing about a person yeah I wish everyone could be queer it's the
我拍的那部电影，里面的主演，是一个非常棒的、非二元性别的人，我非常喜欢ta，ta跟我讲了一个非常美丽的故事，我觉得ta不会介意我分享出来。ta的妈妈也是一位非常优秀的电影人，我是ta的超级粉丝。ta妈妈曾说：我爱你的酷儿身份，我想更多地了解它，这是我最喜欢你的地方之一。我听完哭了，因为我觉得，天哪，这太惊艳了。我已经听够了诸如“尽管如此我还是爱你”或者“不管怎样我都爱你”之类的话，我甚至希望你能因为这个而爱我，因为这是我最喜欢我自己的地方之一。是的，我不是指家庭关系，我只是泛指，这是一个人的美妙之处。是的，我希望每个人都能成为酷儿，它是
best thing about being alive it really is what why do you say that like when you talk about well I guess it's like that visibility we're talking about the community the community it's even outside of the relationships and queer intimacy, which is also stunning. Yeah. Well, we were talking about that earlier. Like that book that I've been reading that was really, really interesting and how it was about non-monogamy. Yeah, open relationships, polyamory, and how so much of the hetero conceptualization of that idea has come from inspiration from queer culture and queer identities and
是的，我们之前也聊过这个。就像我一直在读的那本书，真的非常非常有趣，它是关于非一夫一妻制的。是的，开放式关系、多边恋，许多关于这个概念的异性恋概念化理解，实际上都汲取了酷儿文化、酷儿身份的灵感，以及那些在女同性恋社群及其他群体中采纳了这种生活方式的人们。他们彼此之间的关系，几乎被异性恋者当作了如何接近此类概念的灵感来源，这太让人着迷、太有趣了。老实说，我希望每个人都能一窥我和酷儿朋友们的所有对话，因为他们关于连接、关于导航——我今天刚好在进行一场关于“异花授粉”（cross-pollination）的美妙对话。
people who have adopted that within like lesbian communities and whatnot and how the relationships that they have with each other has kind of almost been taken as inspiration for how us as a hetero person approaches concepts like that it's like so fascinating so interesting honestly I wish everyone could get a little portal into all the conversations I have with my queer friends because they, about connection and about navigate, like I was having this gorgeous conversation today about cross-pollination.
哦，那是什么意思？基本上就像是一张网。特别是我们目前身处悉尼的加迪格尔（Gadigal）土地上。在内西区，酷儿社群非常密集。每个人都认识每个人，每个人都和每个人上过床，每个人，这非常交织在一起。我们今天就在讨论如何驾驭这种关系，而且我在这方面有很多经验，
So, oh, what does that mean? Essentially, like, the web. So, especially we're currently on Gadigal land in Sydney. And in the inner west, the queer community is quite dense. Everyone knows each other, everyone's fucked each other, everyone, it's very interwoven. and we were talking today about how to navigate that, and I've had a lot of experience in that,
我想我们最终得出的结论是：如果你和某人有连接，如果你想要某人，永远走出去，去争取它。就像那样，你应当——当然，这取决于每个人的道德罗盘、关系和动态——但这也是关于沟通，关于体贴他人的感受。酷儿群体，因为我们一直都必须这样做。我们的圈子比异性恋世界要小得多。我们已经学会了这些技能，如何去——虽然不总是这样，
and I think we came down to that if you have a connection with someone, if you want someone, always go out, go for that. Like that, you should, again, depends on everyone's moral compasses and relationships and dynamics, but also it's all about communication, and it's all about being conscious of other people's feelings, and like queer people, because we have to do that all the time. Our pool is a lot smaller than the hetero world. We have learnt these skills of how to, not always,
因为有时候真的很棘手，但是，你知道，每个人都和他们的前任或是某个前任是朋友。每个人都认识朋友的朋友，他们互相睡过、约会过，不管怎样。这一切都如此交织。你必须学会这些技能，这真的很美妙。但回到为什么我酷爱酷儿社群——
because sometimes it's really tricky, but, you know, everyone is friends with their exes or one of their exes. Everyone knows friends of friends who have slept with each other, seeing each other, whatever it is. It's so interwoven. You have to learn these skills, and it's really gorgeous. But going back to why I love the queer community, Yeah, I want to hear everything about it.
是的，我渴望听到关于它的一切。我觉得这是一个非常重要的话题。就像如果你身处外界，是一个“酷儿新手”（baby queer）。什么是酷儿新手？酷儿新手。你是一个酷儿，可能还没出柜，或者没有太多的社群支持。哦天哪，这真的很美妙，因为无论在哪里——我去年刚去美国，那是我第一次以出柜且身为酷儿的身份去海外。无论我去到哪里，只要去酷儿酒吧、活动、跨性别空间，不管是什么，
I feel like it's such an important thing to talk about. It's like if you're out there and you're a baby queer. What is a baby queer? A baby queer. You're queer you maybe haven't come out or you don't have much community. Oh gosh, it is stunning because no matter where, like I just went to the US last year and it was my first time going overseas queer, like out and queer. anywhere anywhere I went I would go to a queer bar event, trans space, whatever,
每一次我都瞬间感到安全，就像和家人在一起一样。这就是走进酷儿空间时的那种感觉，不一定总是同性恋空间，那是另一回事了，但走进酷儿空间。你走进去，人们总是会确保照顾到你，人们总是会和你聊天、欢迎你、包容你。这是一种，就像一个巨大的网络，你可以一头扎进去，大家——每个人都有着相同的共同经历，许多人在孤立中经历过这些，
and every time I instantly felt safe and like I was with family. And that is what it always feels like going into a queer space, not always a gay space, but that's a whole other thing, but going into a queer space. You walk in, people will always make sure they look after you, people will always have chats to you, welcome you, be inclusive. it is this, like this big huge network that you can just dive in and people are, they just, everyone's had the same shared experience and a lot of people have had that in isolation
或者，你知道，完全独自一人在地方上、在天主教学校或女校里，无论是在哪里。每个人都有非常相似的经历，尽管也有所不同，但有一个核心的共同点。所以它以一种——你知道的，这就是为什么——小小的社群将你连接在一起。我们称之为“精选家庭”（chosen family），你知道的，因为许多酷儿的家人并不总是接受他们或理解他们。所以，就像，圣诞节期间，我参加了酷儿们的圣诞聚会，那里充满了社群的氛围，简直美极了。我不知道还能说什么。这真的是我最喜欢的活着的美好事物之一，因为它将
or, you know, completely by themselves regionally in their Catholic or girl school, whatever it is. Everyone has had a very similar experience and different ones, but like a core thing. So it just connects you in a way that, you know, that's why a little, community. Well, we call it chosen family, you know, because a lot of queer people's family don't always accept them or understand them. So, like, you know, over Christmas, I went to queer Christmases and it was just filled with community and it was so gorgeous. I don't know what else to say. I just, it's one of my favorite things about being alive because it integrates
所有这些不同类型的关系结构融合在了一起。它融入了家庭、友谊、爱，以及浪漫之爱，将它们融合成一个巨大的——我一直在说“大杂烩”（sest pot）。虽然词用得不对，但，不是的，就像是一个美妙的社群。美味的菜肴。哦，太美味了。这听起来真的很美妙。
all of these different kind of relationship structures. It puts in family and it puts in friendship and love and like romantic love into one huge, I keep saying sest pot. That is not it, but like, no, but like a gorgeous, community. Yummy dish. Oh, yum. It's gorgeous. It does sound really beautiful.
这真是一个了不起的观点，尤其是正如你所说的那样，关于“酷儿新手”，我从没听过这个词。我觉得这是有史以来最美丽的词组。听到这里的人，或者甚至是你制作的电影——它的目标受众是那些可能处于相当黑暗空间、
That's an amazing, I think, outlook, and especially when, as you were talking about, like, the baby queers, I've never heard that. I think that's, like, the most beautiful phrase ever. And people here were saying, like, you're listening to this, or even the film you made, which was targeted towards people who might be in like a pretty dark space
或是相当孤立空间、可能还没能对自己和周围人坦诚相待的人。现在可能有人正在收听节目，经历着非常相似的事情，并且真的在质疑，你知道，他们是否真的想出柜，以及这对于他们的社群、文化群体和家庭来说是不是一件正确的事情。
or in a pretty isolating space who haven't maybe been able to be truthful with themselves or those around them. And there might be people who are listening to this right now who are going through something really similar and who are really questioning, you know, whether they do want to come out and whether that's the right thing for them to do
他们听着这些可能会感到恐惧，也可能会感到兴奋。所以，对于处在这种境况中的人，你有什么智慧之言或任何建议吗？我认为出柜这件事相当过时，因为如果你处于某种处境，让你觉得出柜对你的家庭、文化群体、宗教群体或其他任何群体而言并不安全——我这里用的是双引号的“出柜”——为了你自身的安全，你可以选择不对那些人出柜，但你依然可以接触社群，无论是在网上还是在实体空间，这取决于你的具体情况。这不需要是一夜之间发生的一件大事。
in their community and their cultural group and their family. and they might be listening to this with fear or excitement. So do you have any words of wisdom, any advice for people who are in that situation? I think that coming out is quite archaic because if you are in a position that you do not feel safe to, I'm putting air quotes, come out with your family or cultural group or religious group or whatever it is, you can, for your own safety, not come out to those people, but you can still access community, whether that be online or whether that be in physical spaces depending on your situation, that it doesn't need to be this huge overnight.
我出柜了并且为此骄傲，你知道的，去你的，支持我吧。完全不需要这样。如果你需要分阶段来做，如果你只需要在安全的空间里这么做，那也是可以的。这没关系，因为这完全取决于你和你自身的安全，这正是困难所在，也是我一直向大家反复强调的一点：酷儿身份的很大一部分关乎安全。这就是为什么我们聚集在社群里，这就是为什么我们有自己的回音室，因为我们在外面的世界并不总是感到安全。在海外，许多不同的国家都有许多反酷儿的法律，我们聚集在海狸酒吧（bearded tibed），
I'm out and proud, you know, fuck you, support me. It doesn't need to be that. If you need to stagger it, if you need to have it in only safe spaces, that is okay. it is it doesn't matter because it is up to you and your safety and that's what's really hard and I drill home about all of this as well that so much of queerness is about safety that's why we gather in community that's why we have our echo chambers is because we do not feel safe out in the world all the time overseas there's so many anti-queer laws in so many different countries like there is a reason we congregate at the bearded tibed
你知道的，在不同的聚会场所，这是有原因的，因为那是属于我们的地方。然后我还要说，这一切都在向你走来。无论你现在拥有它与否。如果你现在还没有、也感受不到这一切，我真的向你送去满满的爱。但我向你保证，请坚持下去，因为有许许多多的小角落。属于你的人终究会出现，你会找到他们的。这真的很惊艳。
and, you know, are different watering holes because that is the place. And then I also say, it is all coming for you. Whether you have it right now, you don't. And I really am sending so much love to you if you do not have that right now and you don't feel it's accessible. But I just promise you to hold out because there's so many little pockets. There's going to be the people that are yours and you're going to find them. It's stunning.
而且，你知道的，那是不同的栖息地，因为那就是那个地方。然后我也说，这一切终将降临到你身上。无论你现在是否拥有它，你都没有。如果你现在没有这一切，也觉得它遥不可及，我真的向你送去无限的爱。但我向你保证，坚持下去，因为有那么多的小角落。总会有属于你的人，而你会找到他们的。这太美妙了。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目《2%》中，我将剖析这个奇异现代世界中关于心理韧性、健身和培养抗压能力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，带大家看透那些充斥着健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。
industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people.
我们曾坚信种子油本质上会引起炎症。我们错了。世界上许多让我们感到恐慌的问题，其实都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。收听《2%》。就在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts，或者你获取播客的任何地方。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小姬姆的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。
I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do a little kill? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It Podcast. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill,
我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小姬姆到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《Look Back at It》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集我们都会深入探讨发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的对话，
waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed correct. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence.
大谈80年代的可卡因。坦白讲，84年对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为可卡因。我随时都可以聊聊可卡因，只是让大家知道而已。我的意思是，马克，这是我们第二集讨论可卡因了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在台面上了。谢谢你帮我把这句话说完。
Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
是的。我认为没有哪一年对黑人来说比这更重要了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。
Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing,
欢迎收听我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》，我是主持人，也是你最喜欢的治疗师卡尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己十多年在心理健康领域的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是特里普·方丹、瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，
we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth?
我们会太过于投入追逐的过程，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，我们甚至不知道什么时候才算够了，因为人们总是在看记分板。生活变成了一场关于输赢的比赛。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，你觉得在这个世界上活着成为一个好人重要吗？
Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway.
你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。完全正确。这也是两个不同层次的信任。我希望你纯粹只是想做一个好人。加入我和卡尔·盖恩斯的行列，在我的新播客《Learn the Hardway》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。
Open your free, Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself, at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth.
打开你免费的IHeart Radio应用程序。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《黄金单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己卷入了一场亲子鉴定丑闻。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这拉开了长达数年的法律战的序幕，旨在证明真相。
You doctored this particular test twice in someone's, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern.
你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一大批互联网侦探来破案。我希望人们能看到他们的税款都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会揭露一个令人不安的模式。
Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Lesbian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences.
另外两个经历过同样事情的男子。莱斯利、迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。我是斯蒂芬妮·扬。这是《Love Trap》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察局。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。
Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to LoveTrapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app,
女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这还没完。在IHeart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或你获取播客的任何地方收听《LoveTrapped》播客，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. podcasts. Claude, you do some amazing things for your emotional and your mental and your spiritual well-being, I would say, that really kind of, I think, drew me to you when we first met. And then as I started following along with like some of the things you're posting online and then some of the discussions we've had recently, it's just become even more prominent to me.
播客。克劳德，你为你的情感、心理和精神健康做了一些了不起的事情，我想说，正是这些事情在我们刚见面时深深吸引了我。然后当我开始关注你在网上发布的一些内容，以及我们最近进行的一些讨论时，它对我来说变得更加突出了。
Like, what an amazing inspiration you are for the specific like activities that you do that really help, like, re-senter you. Can you talk a bit about them? I want to hear about the solo dates in particular. I feel like this is... The solo dates. The solo dates is like one of the best ideas I've heard in a long time. Well, I think solo dates is something we've all heard about, but I have a structure that I've been doing for the last three years. Yeah. Um, that every month I go on a solo date to an Italian restaurant. You can choose your own. You don't have to be Italian. That's just what I like. To be Vietnamese. Whatever you like, but I like to do Italian, I love Italian food.
比如，你所做的那些真正有助于让你重新找回自我的特定活动，是多么不可思议的灵感。你能谈谈它们吗？我想特别听听独自约会的事。我觉得这个……独自约会。独自约会是我听过的最棒的主意之一。嗯，我认为独自约会是我们都听说过的事情，但我有一个坚持了三年的结构。对。嗯，每个月我都会去一家意大利餐厅独自约会。你可以选择你自己的。不一定非得是意大利菜。那只是我喜欢。也可以是越南菜。无论你喜欢什么，但我喜欢意大利菜，我超爱意大利菜。
Oh, me too. And I book myself into a restaurant. I bring my journal. And every time as well I book, they're always like, just for one person. I'm like, yeah, babe. Well, at the start of the solo dates, I would be a bit timid. And be like, yeah, it's just me. But no, now I'm like, yes, it's just me.
哦，我也是。我给自己预订了一家餐厅。我带上我的日记。而且每次我预订的时候，他们总是问，就一个人吗？我就说，对啊，宝贝。好吧，在独自约会的初期，我可能会有点羞涩。会说，对，就我一个人。但不了，现在我会说，没错，就我一个人。
I go to a different Italian restaurant every single time. And I have these set of questions that I, you know, ask myself where I journal about them. So I will put like my date number where I'm at physically, like the location. Yeah. And then I ask myself, what did you do today? And I write in extreme detail because that will be so interesting to look back on when I'm an old, old person. Yeah. and then what are you proud of yourself for?
每次我都去不同的意大利餐厅。我有一组固定的问题，你知道的，我会问自己，并在日记里写下来。所以我会写下我的约会编号、我当时身处的物理位置，也就是地点。对。然后我问自己，你今天做了什么？我用极度详细的词句写下来，因为等我变成一个老头老太太时，回过头来看会非常有趣。对。然后你会为自己感到骄傲的是什么？
And I do little dot points. And then the last three texts I receive because I think that's just another interesting thing to see. And I've been doing that every single month for the last three years. And it is such a beautiful thing, like a gift to yourself every month, but also a moment of reflection and to see what you're looking forward to,
我会写下一些要点。还有我收到的最后三条短信，因为我觉得这也是一个很有趣的观察点。过去三年里，我每个月都在这样做。这是一件如此美好的事情，就像每个月送给自己的礼物，同时也是一个反思的时刻，看看你在期待什么，
where you've been, where you're at. And at the end of every solo date, I read the entry from the month before. And it's wild. Every time I say, what are you looking forward to or what do you want? Everything happens. Like, it always does. And also, like, it could be big things.
你曾去过哪里，你现在在哪里。每次独自约会结束时，我都会阅读前一个月的日记。这太疯狂了。每次我问你在期待什么或者你想要什么时。所有事情都会发生。真的总是这样。而且，这可能是一些大事。
It could be small things. But it just keeps you on track for what you really want in your life. And I think having rituals like that is just a really gorgeous thing to be able to check in with yourself and continually check in with your gut and that you're on the path that you want to be on because we have a short time on this earth. We really do, but it's also the longest thing we're ever going to know because it's like human, you know,
也可能是小事。但这能让你朝着你真正想要的生活轨迹前进。我认为拥有这样的仪式感是一件非常美好的事情，它能让你与自己保持联系，不断审视自己的直觉，确保你走在自己想要的道路上，因为我们在世的时间很短。确实很短，但它也是我们所能经历的最长的事情，因为它是人类的，你知道的，
the human time. Like that's all we know, but it's the longest but also shortest thing because it's inevitably going to end. So I want to be living my life how I fucking want to be. I want to be doing what I want. I want to be following my gut. I want to be always,
人类的时间。这就是我们所知道的一切，但它既是最长的也是最短的，因为它终究会结束。所以我想按照我他妈想要的方式生活。我想做我想做的事。我想听从我的直觉。我希望永远，
prioritising my well-being, my pleasure, my joy. And so it's a way for me to continually do that because it's very easy in life to get swept away and feel monotonous or disassociated or out of touch and get into a routine that you're not in touch with yourself. So it really allows for me to continually check in. Yeah. And I feel like those rituals are such an important part of our 20s, right? And I love what you're saying about knowing that, like, and hoping that you're going to get to the age where you can be reflective on these points and being like, I'm going to be able to track my development and like my goals and things like that.
把我的幸福、我的快乐、我的喜悦放在首位。所以这是我不断这样做的一种方式，因为在生活中很容易随波逐流，感到单调乏味、麻木或者与自己脱节，陷入一种让你与自己失去联系的常规中。所以它确实让我能够不断地进行自我检查。是的。我觉得这些仪式感是我们二十多岁时非常重要的一部分，对吧？我很喜欢你所说的，知道并希望你能达到这样一个年龄，能够对这些事情进行反思，并且觉得，我将能够追踪我的发展、我的目标诸如此类的事情。
And also I read back these entries from, like, you know, a few years ago. And the things that when I would say, what's in your mind or what's in your heart and I'd read those splurges of my anxieties or whatever was happening, years later, months later, that's fluff. I don't remember it or it's not important to me anymore. And it teaches me that when I'm feeling anxious about something or my brain is spiraling about something, that that is always transitory. Like it isn't going to be there for long. So if you're feeling it, let it swell, but also there are times to externalize and step
而且我也重读了这些日记，比如，你知道的，几年前的。当我说出“你心里在想什么”或“你心裡有什么”时，我去阅读那些宣泄焦虑或当时发生的事情的文字，几年后，几个月后，那些都是浮云。我不记得了，或者对我来说已经不重要了。它教会我，当我为某事感到焦虑或我的大脑在为某事疯狂旋转时，那总是暂时的。它不会停留太久。所以如果你感受到了，就让它翻涌吧，但同时也有需要抽离和走出来的时刻，
out of it because it's really not going to be there forever. Some things are, but a lot of things. are just going to float away and you're not going to really remember it. Yeah. I have this saying that I stay quite a bit on the podcast, which is that like if it's not going to matter in five years, you shouldn't think about it for longer than five minutes. If it's not going to matter for a month, you shouldn't, you know?
因为它们真的不会永远存在。有些事情会，但很多事情只是会飘走，你根本不会真正记住。是的。我有一句在播客里经常说的话，那就是，如果这件事在五年内不重要，你就不应该为它花超过五分钟去想。如果它一个月后都不重要，你难道不应该……
Well, that's the thing, right? It's like, and I totally have that experience as well, which is like why I also am a huge proponent of journaling, of in some way keeping track of your journey through life. I like read back on this journal entry from like 2017 which is what like six years ago yeah and I was like talking about this person I was like I'm not going to say their name because I feel like
嗯，就是这样，对吧？就像，我完全也有过那种经历，这就是为什么我也大力主张写日记，以某种方式记录你的人生旅程。我喜欢重读2017年左右的日记，那大约是六年前吧，是的。我当时在谈论这个人，我说，我不会说出他们的名字，因为我觉得
I don't know they are a real person but I was like let's call them Lucy I was like Lucy said this really mean thing to me and then you know Anna was like saying this thing and that and I was so annoyed and I was so mad and like blah blah I don't even remember who those people are. Like, I was reading back on that journal entry and I was like, who is Anna? Who is Lucy? Like, I don't have any idea of who they are. But I think that, like, especially in this, like, this decade of life where it's like, this is our first decade of adulthood, everything feels so permanent and so
我不知道他们是不是真实存在的人，但我想，我们叫她露西吧。我说，露西对我说了一件很mean的话，然后你知道安娜又说了这样那样的话，我超级烦，我超级生气，然后巴拉巴拉。我甚至都不记得那些人是谁了。就像，我重读那篇日记时心想，安娜是谁？露西是谁？我根本不知道他们是谁。但我觉得，尤其是在这个十年的人生阶段里，这是我们成年的第一个十年，一切都感觉那么永久、那么
severe. And we no longer have, like, the shelter of our families and the shelter of being young to kind of protect us. Things can feel so much more serious than they actually are. But also, flip that we are still so young. Your 20s, we were talking about this before, are famously the time of making mistakes, experimenting, working out who you are. So it's also, that it's okay to go through all those growing pains still, you know, you're not, you haven't got your shit sorted in your 20s whatsoever. Yeah. No, literally, I feel like, and it's so interesting, I think like meeting other people who are doing something similar and like doing a creative thing and being like whoa like this is I never expected that I'd end up here and I always think about
严峻。我们不再有家庭的庇护，也没有年轻作为保护伞来庇护我们。事情往往会比实际情况看起来要严重得多。但同时，反过来想，我们依然那么年轻。正如我们之前讨论的那样，二十多岁出了名是犯错、实验、弄清楚你是谁的时期。所以，经历所有这些成长的痛苦也是没问题的，你知道的，你在二十多岁时根本不可能把生活理得井井有条。是的。不，真的，我觉得，这太有趣了，我想结识其他人，他们也在做类似的事情，比如做一些有创意的事，然后心想，哇，我从没想过我会走到这一步，我总是会想起
who I was 10 years ago or five years ago and I'm like whoa this person would never have really been able to conceptualize or have any understanding of you know the loves that I've had the mistakes that I've made the moves that I've made like and that's going to keep you keep happening. I know. And that's like actually such a beautiful thing to me. Because I think sometimes I get quite worried about like the passing of time and I'm like, oh my God, this is so stressful that life is so finite and there's so much I want to do. And, you know, time just keeps passing. And then I'm like, the fact that I like look back on the last five years of my life and I'm like, you know, in five years time, I won't be 30. I won't even be 30 yet. And I will have all of those
回看十年前或五年前的自己，我就会想，天哪，这个人绝对无法真正理解或想象我经历过的爱情、犯过的错误、做过的决定，而这种变化会一直持续下去。我知道。对我和说，这其实是一件非常美好的事。因为我觉得有时我会很担心时间的流逝，心想，天哪，生命如此有限，而我想做的事又那么多，时间却一直在流逝，这太让人焦虑了。然后我又转念一想，当我回首过去五年的生活时，就会觉得，五年后我甚至还不到30岁，而我将拥有所有这些
experiences and so many more yet again. And like, I just cannot wait for it. It makes me feel so optimistic to reflect and then also look forward. I don't know if you have that same experience. I've always loved getting older. I've always, I've, every time I get a year old, I go, thank the Lord. Just I love getting older.
经历，甚至还会经历更多。我简直迫不及待了。回首过去并展望未来让我感到无比乐观。我不知道你们有没有这种体验。我一直很喜欢变老。每当我长大一岁，我都会说，感谢上帝。我就是喜欢变老。
I can't wait. I love being this age. I'm excited to be my 30s. I'm excited to be my 40s. I'm excited to be in my 50s. I don't want to rush it, but I love getting older. I love juicing more experiences up and becoming who. I am because every year it gets better.
我等不及了。我喜欢现在的年龄。我很期待自己的30多岁，期待40多岁，期待50多岁。我不想催促时间，但我就是喜欢变老。我喜欢体验更多的人生经历，活出真实的自我，因为每一年都比前一年更好。
Like, it's also hard. Like last year was fucking hard. But it was every year I'm just getting closer and closer to myself. And I was saying to you before, and this might be different. And Claudia, in a year's time would be like, what the fuck, man? What are you saying? But I don't get nervous anymore. I feel so confident in myself.
当然，生活也很艰难。比如去年就操蛋得很。但每一年，我都离真实的自己更近了一步。我刚才也跟你说过，情况可能会有所不同。克劳迪娅一年后可能会觉得，你特么在说什么呀？但我现在真的不紧张了。我对自我感到无比自信。
And that is so cool. And maybe, you know, I like to say this quote I heard somewhere, which is you will lose yourself over and over again and you will find yourself over and over again. So I'm sure there are times I will feel extremely nervous and anxious and all those things. But as I keep getting older, I just feel more in myself. And I think that's a really nice thing to look forward to because time gives you that. Well, yeah, like you did go through a really rough time last year. Like we talked about this the other day, right? And it was, I didn't live it. and even hearing you speak about it, I was like, that sounds awful and so traumatic.
这真的很酷。也许，正如我听过的一句名言所说：你会一遍又一遍地迷失自我，也会一遍又一遍地找回自我。所以我确信，有时我还是会感到极度紧张、焦虑和诸如此类的情绪。但随着年龄的增长，我感觉自己更加笃定了。我觉得这是一个非常美好的、值得期待的改变，因为时间会赋予你这种力量。嗯，对啊，你去年确实经历了一段非常艰难的时期。我们前几天还聊过这个，对吧？我虽然没有亲身经历，但听你讲起时，还是觉得那听起来太可怕、太创伤了。
And so what do you think is, well, you know, there's been circumstantial things that have changed, but like the fact that you're talking about, you're talking about how you don't have any anxiety and how your life just keeps getting better, like, why do you think you've been able to shift into that perspective? Like, what do you think has changed in the way you see the world or the way you address your life or focus on your life? Yeah. And it's created that shift because I'm sure that a lot of people are listening to this being like, wow, living without anxiety. That sounds absolutely blessed. Well, I also want to acknowledge that a lot of people, you know, have anxiety or depression
所以你觉得——虽然有一些客观环境的变化，但正如你所说，你现在没有焦虑了，生活也越来越好——你觉得为什么自己能够转变这种心态呢？你觉得你看待世界的方式、处理生活的方式或关注生活的方式发生了什么变化，从而带来了这种转变？因为我相信很多听众听到这里都会觉得，哇，过着没有焦虑的生活听起来太幸福了。不过我也想承认，很多人其实都经历着焦虑或抑郁
or any other kind of, um... Yeah, mental health conditions. Exactly. That is outside of their control. And I'm not like, woo, life is great. Just live on the bright side. But for me, uh, my mom, uh, was diagnosed with cancer last year. And that was heinous. It was, she's, she's fine. now. She's in remission, which is great. But, yeah, it was, it was heinous.
或其他任何种类的……对，心理健康状况。没错。那是他们无法控制的。我并不是在说，哇，生活太美好了，只管看光明的一面就行。但对我来说，我妈妈去年被诊断出患有癌症。那简直太糟糕了。她现在没事了，已经康复了，这太棒了。但是，那段经历确实非常煎熬。
And I was also going through a breakup at the same time. So those two, and like my first big breakup. So the two were kind of hitting off each other. But since, you know, healing from both of those things, a huge perspective shift happened, which was if I wake up and circumstantial things I cannot control, everything is shit and I can't control that, them fair enough to feel all those things. But if I wake up and everything is okay for the most
而且我当时还在经历分手。这两件事——这也是我的第一次大分——同时向我袭来。但在从这两件事中恢复过来之后，我发生了一种巨大的心态转变，那就是：如果我醒来发现一些我无法控制的客观情况一团糟，而我又无能为力，那么我为这些情况感到难过是完全情有可原的。但如果我醒来，我的日常生活在绝大多数情况下
part in my immediate life, like obviously the world is a bit cooked. So, you know, I understand when people can tap into that. But if I wake up and people in my life are alive and well and healthy at this point and then I might as well have the best fucking time and enjoy myself because tragedy is coming for all of us. Pain is coming for all of us. That is inevitable. I watch this a really amazing documentary called Stutz, which I told you to watch. Oh, the one with Jonah Hill. Did you watch it? Yeah, he interviews.
都还算正常——当然，现在这个世界有点疯狂，所以我理解为什么人们会陷入那种消极情绪——但如果我醒来时，我生命中的人们都还活着、安好且健康，那我最好还是过得开心点，尽情享受生活，因为悲剧迟早会降临到我们每个人头上，痛苦也一样，这是不可避免的。我看过一部非常棒的纪录片叫《施茨的疗愈秘诀》（Stutz），我之前让你看的。哦，就是乔纳·希尔的那部？你看过吗？对，他采访了……
I need to watch it. Maybe I'll watch it tonight. You should. Well, he says that, his therapist says that the three constants in life is pain, uncertainty, and constant work. Which I really agree with. But if you wake up and your world is not on fire, try and have the best fucking day, because your world will be on fire some days. And you cannot control that.
我得去看看。也许我今晚就看。你应该看看。嗯，他在里面说，他的治疗师认为生活中有三个恒定不变的东西：痛苦、不确定性和持续不断的工作。我非常赞同这一点。但如果你醒来时，你的世界并没有着火，那就尽量去过好精彩的一天，因为总有一天你的世界会着火，而那是你无法控制的。
not be able to have the best day. So a huge thing that just happened when I thought that my mum was going to die. And then coming out the other side of that is going, okay, great, it didn't happen. Well, I might as well reap all of the joys of life, smell the fucking flowers as I walk around, look at dogs, pat them, go after what I want. Every part of my life I love. Every part of it. And I think that all of us should aim for that if we can, for whatever. whatever, it just in every single way, my career, my friends, my home, my life, everything I love. Yeah. And it's almost like this, I wouldn't say artificial optimism, or forced optimism, but like this attitude of being like, let's see the brightest side here. And I completely agree with
你可能无法度过美好的一天。所以，当我以为我妈妈快要死了，然后从那种阴影中走出来时，一个巨大的感悟就是：好吧，谢天谢地，最坏的事情没有发生，那我最好去收获生活中的所有快乐，走路时去闻闻花香，看看狗狗，摸摸它们，去追求我想要的一切。我爱我生活中的每一个部分，每一个部分都是如此。我觉得我们大家如果可以的话，都应该朝着这个目标努力，不管在哪个方面，无论是我的事业、朋友、家庭、生活，我都爱这一切。对。这几乎就像是一种，我不会说是人工的乐观主义
you. Like, one of my friends was saying to me the other day that her therapist was like, um, listen, like, your life is going to be painful. There are going to be things that you cannot control things that are outside of your comfort zone external things like illnesses like death losing your job but being able to be like what is within my realm of control what am I able to actually like it's almost like a chess game right like you can't control the other person's moves but you can control your own and also then finding things that give you a sense of fulfillment or ease or peace in all of it. Peace is a huge thing for me, is in all of it, how to find a sense of inner peace and acceptance. And when everything was really shit last year, I was living by the ocean and every
或被迫的乐观，而是一种态度，就像是在说：让我们看到光明的一面吧。我完全赞同你的看法。我有个朋友前几天跟我说，她的治疗师告诉她：听着，你的生活注定会伴随痛苦，总会有你无法控制的事情，比如那些超出你舒适区的事情，外部的事情，像疾病、死亡、失业。但关键在于能够分清什么在我的掌控范围内？我究竟能真正掌控什么？这几乎就像是一场国际象棋比赛，对吧？你无法控制对方的走法，但你能控制自己的走法，并且在这一切中找到能带给你成就感、轻松感或平静感的事物。内心的平静对我来说非常重要，也就是如何在这一切中找到内心的平静与接纳。去年一切都糟透了的时候，我住在海边，每天
single day, I'd wake up, I'd get my coffee, I'd go and put it on my special rock, and I'd go for a swim, and every time I put my head under the water and I came up, I felt like a moment of pure joy and catharsis. And then I'd go instead of my rock, drink my coffee, and just journal and always, like having that every morning as a morning ritual was so healing and gorgeous and, again, another gift to myself that I could grant myself. Because in that moment, I couldn't control the pain I was feeling and everything that was happening, but I could give myself that morning every morning and it put me in a really good place. And then, you know, the day would take its course and who knows.
醒来后去买杯咖啡，把它放在我专属的石头上，然后去海里游泳。每次我把头潜入水中再探出水面时，我都感到一种纯粹的快乐和宣泄。然后我会回到我的石头旁，喝着咖啡，写写日记。每天早晨都保持这样的晨间仪式真的非常治愈、非常美好，这也是我送给自己的又一份礼物。因为在那一刻，我无法控制自己感受到的痛苦和正在发生的一切，但我可以每天早晨都给自己这样一段时光，这让我感觉好多了。然后，新的一天顺其自然，谁知道会发生什么呢。
but I think that if you're in a space that things are happening and you can't control it, finding those little rituals that give you some peace is really important. I think that's an amazing point to maybe wrap up. We've had so many conversations. Pain and beauty. Pain and beauty. Yeah, we're kind of philosophizing, aren't we? We're just getting into like very, I feel like every time we talk, we have these very, like,
但我觉得，如果你正处于无法控制各种变故的处境中，找到那些能给你带来平静的小仪式真的很重要。我觉得这是一个非常适合作为收尾的精彩观点。我们聊了太多。痛苦与美丽。痛苦与美丽。对，我们有点在进行哲学探讨了，不是吗？我们深入探讨了……我觉得每次我们聊天都会有这种深刻的……
the conversations just go into this like entirely like we could be teaching a university course right now about hedonism about stoicism and about the the reality of pain and whatnot but um i do want to sincerely thank you for coming on well i want to sincerely thank you for having me on oh my god so much sincerity in one space at one time no it was an amazing it was an amazing experience and um i hope that if you've made it this far, which I hope many of you have, that you've learnt something, you've learned something important. Maybe you were listening to this as a baby queer like you were talking about and who better to take advice from then this amazing person. But also I take so much, not take so much, but I learn so much from queer youth as well, I want to say that like,
谈话最后总是上升到这样的高度，我们现在简直可以在大学开一门关于享乐主义、斯多葛学派以及痛苦的现实等主题的课程了。不过，我真的非常感谢你能来做客。我也非常感谢你邀请我来。天啊，这么短的时间内充满了真诚！不，这真是一次美妙的经历。而且我希望，如果你能听到这里——我希望大家都能听到这里——你一定学到了一些东西，学到了一些重要的东西。也许你听这期节目时正处在青少年的自我探索期，正如你刚才所说，还有谁比这位了不起的人更适合向其取经呢？不过我也必须说，我也从酷儿青年身上学到了很多东西，我想说的是，
it's not just like, oh, the little baby queer, it's like, they are the future and they are teaching us everything and they are on it. Honestly, like, I feel like this, I feel like often when we talk, like the narratives around the queer community are often, like we said, politicise. So it's like really beautiful that you came on and we're talking about community and something that I think is not often recognized by people beyond that space and beyond that identity and beyond that community. It's the best kept secret.
这不仅仅是说“哦，可爱的小酷儿”，而是他们代表了未来，他们在教导我们一切，他们真的很有主见。说实话，我觉得每次我们聊天时，围绕酷儿社群的叙事往往就像我们刚才说的，被政治化了。所以你能来做客，和我们聊聊社群，聊聊那些在这个空间、这个身份和这个社群之外的人们往往不太了解的事情，这真的很美好。这是个保守得最好的秘密。
It is a beautiful secret. And I'm so glad that you shared it with me. I feel very, very privileged and very blessed. So the listeners. Yes, and you listeners. You're in on the secret as well. Oh, a little secret circle. well thank you for coming on
这是一个美丽的秘密。我很高兴你把它分享给了我。我感到非常荣幸，也非常幸福。还有听众们。是的，还有你们这些听众，你们也知道了这个秘密。哦，这是一个秘密小圈子。谢谢你来做客
and if you did enjoy this episode please feel free to leave a five-star review on Apple Podcasts Spotify whatever you are listening right now follow us on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast if you want to hear more I'm sure I'd also tag you there
如果你喜欢这一集，请随时在 Apple Podcasts、Spotify 或你现在收听的任何平台上留下五星好评，并关注我们的 Instagram 账号 @That Psychology Podcast。如果你想听更多内容，我确信我也会在那里@你。
hopefully oh you know you know what's going to happen so if you want to follow along with their work I would really recommend it you can maybe you should pin that post about your solo Italian dates. I don't know how to pin things, but I'll learn. It's incredible. I really, I want that to be like common knowledge. How to pin things or the solo days?
希望如此。哦，你知道接下来会发生什么。所以如果你想关注他们的作品，我真的强烈推荐。也许你该置顶那篇关于你独自去意大利旅行的帖子的。我不知道怎么置顶，但我会学的。这太不可思议了。我真的希望这能成为常识。是学习怎么置顶还是独自旅行？
Both. Okay. I'll learn how to pin. The solo dates. Yeah. I'll let's give you a tutorial. And thank you again for listening and we will see you next week for another episode. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast.
两个都学。好吧，我会学怎么置顶的。至于独自旅行，对，我们给你做个教程。再次感谢大家的收听，我们下周同一时间再见，收听另一期节目。嘿，大家好！欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆（Kear Games）主持的《The Hard Way》。这个节目聚焦黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他地方根本无法安全进行的坦诚对话，而你是在和一个懂得如何处理这些问题的持证专业人士一起交流。有多少男人带着盔甲生活？这向世界发出了一个信号，表明你是不好惹的。但仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这么做。请在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also. Also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships,
2%。这就是在有电梯可用时选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter）。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析心理韧性、健身以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO%. On the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist.
你就会破茧成蝶，成为一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的人。请收听《2%》。名字就是数字 2%。在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个声名狼藉的骗子约会过时，
They take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe.
她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓，我将成为他的最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的惩罚。我们总是说，相信你的闺蜜。听闺蜜的话，相信我，宝贝。
On the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at a podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 is big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year,
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听。在《Look Back At It》播客中。回到 1979 年，对我来说那是一个重大的时刻。84 年对我意义重大。我是萨姆·J（Sam J.），我是亚历克斯·英格利士（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，
unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
剖析当时发生了什么，并试图和我们的朋友、喜剧演员同行以及最喜欢的作家一起，理清我们是如何在那个时代存活下来的。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）谈论 80 年代。84 年是一个疯狂的年份。那真的是个疯狂的年份。对于黑人来说，再也没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Thank you. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在 iHeartRadio App、Apple Podcasts 或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back At It》。这是一个 iHeart 播客。人类品质保证。谢谢。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。